[Music]
I found the best way to stand out is to
trust your gut it's very easy to over
calculate over produce a brand for us we
like to really focus on making things
more approachable more vibrant standing
out from the shelves so make sure that
the packaging is there to get the
purchase the price Point's there to make
it an easy sale that's the
key my name is Evan Schuman I am the
President of lella Winery I am Marissa
Sergey Schuman the
CEO I got started in wine making from a
very young age I actually have a
elementary school memory book that I
wrote my my goals and dreams and I know
in fifth grade I wrote that I wanted to
be a wine
maker I have been surrounded by the
Italian tradition of wine making from
birth pretty much my grandparents
immigrating here from Italy bringing
that tradition always having my father's
friends over for dinner meals and just
seeing that growing up was really
special so every fall they would bring
in fresh grapes and crush it in our our
backyard and it was so much fun trying
the fresh juice and when my father
started lofa Bella in the early 2000s I
was in seventh or eighth grade and
seeing that come together was really
exciting so I was like wow what could I
do when I graduate high school and
realized that Cornell University offered
a anology and vulture program which is a
science of wine making and grape growing
and fast forward to 2020 EV and I came
together and put our life savings into
uh down payment to afford our SBA loan
to fully acquire the business for my
parents so they could retire and we
could uh write our own next chapter of
Bella our company was originally founded
as a juice business and as a a home wine
making supply store so back in the early
2000s when MC's father first started the
business we are bringing in wine juices
from different parts of the world and
selling them to the local market here
for people that wanted to take the juice
home and ferment it into into wine so as
the business progressed and we had
product left over at the end of the
season we'd ferment that out and turn
into wine and hence how the winery first
started so today it's still a piece of
our business it's only about 25 to 30%
of our Revenue we've of course
significantly grown our our wine
business to overtake that that aspect of
our company but again today it's still a
a portion of our business the area that
we just walked through is our Dock and
staging area so all orders that go out
of this facility are staged in the dock
area and then and of course go out from
that that
[Music]
warehouse we decided to stay here in
Ohio both I believe for family purposes
and of course the winery is being
founded in Ohio many of our products
were imported from other regions of the
United States and so when we decided to
acquire the company of course it just
made sense to stay here in our home
Market where the facility is and we're a
bit unique in terms of how we operate as
a winery because we don't grow any of
our own grapes so while we don't have
the luxury of having our own estate we
do have the luxury of being able to grow
quickly because we don't have the
restrictions of our own Vineyard to
restrict our growth so because of that
we are able to Source product from all
over the country and we're able to
produce all kinds of unique products
that aren't limited to specific regions
and that's what's been unique for us to
be able to grow our our business so for
us being in Ohio is only a value ad
because we're right in the midst of our
major retailers and it just allows us to
be closer to our
customers my name is Garett Lano and I'm
the head wine maker here at Louella I
think Louella being in this this area is
great because you know we were able to
sort of fly under the radar a bit and
and build our Our Brands
up' been able to hire some people here
give you know others an opportunity in
this area and kind of get out our our
products and it's it's Unique because
it's not you know we're not in
California you know fighting with 20
other wineries around us we're sort of
isolated here so it's nice that you know
we have that and we're able to kind of
be a big player and a small area but yet
as we do that expand outwards
too so these are our four outdoor
fermentation tanks so the the basics of
fermentation is sugar and yeast and that
bubbling shows us that it's a nice
active healthy fermentation so each of
these is about 7200 gallons and these
are fully jacketed and temperature
controlled so we can do fermentations
out here any time of the
year we found that a lot of our
consumers are looking for sweeter
profiles and what was really exciting
about our opportunity being located in
Ohio a lot of our customers are looking
for that profile
locally when we're sourcing more local
grape it's able to be of a high quality
wine but able to pass on that savings
for our customer which allows us to be
well priced in the retail space without
sacrificing quality so being able to
take our talents with wine making and
knowing branding and marketing we've
coupled that into making well balanced
profiles that match vibrant brands in
[Music]
[Applause]
store my name is Jeff Stone I represent
corporate Affairs in public relations in
the Walmart and Borgman Ohio 2017 2016
there was a young lady that came to the
Columbus Market I was actually a store
manager back then and she was selling
and promoting and pitching her wine I
never knew who she was but when she left
I never would forget her because it was
such a great discussion and conversation
about the product she talked about how
it was manufactured here in Ohio which
piqued my interest it's very important
to promote Ohio branded product because
we know that when we promote us
Manufacturing in Ohio it's going to
create jobs it's going to satisfy the
customers and it's going to serve the
needs of our community because we're
creating
jobs is great value good quality at a
fantastic
price the types of customers that we are
focused on are of course genz and
Millennials but we also have a large
Market in the age brackets between 25
and 45 specifically women but also men
between 35 and
I am Nikki Fury I work for family
business which is Sparkle markets I'm
Steve mcti I'm the senior director for
beer one and liquor for Giant
Eagle most of the customers that buy
this wine are like me they're women
they're in their mid 20s to like their
early 40s and they really love the
Purple Rain that's our number one seller
through all of our Sparkle
markets they don't look like a lot of
other wine brands that are very you know
maybe a classic look so I think they've
gone after a wider demographic and I
think the the brand has that type of
appeal to it that's the thing that's
really created so much excitement for
our
customers they just love it because it
is sweet it's fruity and it's a nice
introduction to
Wine Our Brands are are great for new
wine consumers that are curious about
the space because our labels aren't
chatau facing most of them especially
are passion brand you could almost taste
the wine by looking at the label bold
fruit the alcohol percentage is
highlighted in a nice Circle so you
don't have to search it for many minutes
in the wine aisle trying to figure out
the location we have easy descriptors
and a profile that's sweet crisp
refreshing well balanced something that
is very approachable for anyone that's
either a wine consumer or just curious
about
wine over the course of the business
we've raised around $3 million between
debt and Equity the last valuation raise
was at a 15 million post money valuation
since we have acquired the business our
distribution footprint has grown 300%
we've entered nine new markets since the
acquisition in terms of retailer growth
we've grown anywhere between 120 and
1200% in any specific retailer from joh
Eagle to walm Mar to Meyer and we've
been able to maintain growth year every
year even with New Market entry and
maintaining a
foothold we've also grown steady
depletions on average anywhere between
25 to 30% year-over-year in terms of
total Global depletions in all of our
[Music]
markets
we definitely consider
ourselves a growing company but also an
underdog it depends on who's looking at
us I feel that the wine industry as a
whole like the wineries that are
producing products for retail might not
still see us as a big player but our
retailers see our data our sell through
and the opportunity with working with us
so we've been able to expand to quite
amount of doors the last 2 years because
of what we've been able to accomplish on
the Shelf but we're kind of balancing
that out right now which it's a really
exciting time for
us the biggest misconception for being a
young entrepreneur is that we're not
experienced we're not prepared and what
I love to do is walk into a room knowing
my facts figures and all the data and
showing that any room any opportunity
that we've came prepared and ready to
Rocket being a young
entrepreneur Evan and myself lived out
of a suitcase for over 8 years couch
surfing cheap hotels going anywhere we
could to spread the word about the
product what we're doing and when we
Clos on our home it was such an amazing
feeling but also I was able to pack and
unpack my makeup bag for the first time
in 8 years so it was really exciting and
we really cherish our time at home and
our Greatful for those moments as
well being married and operating a
business together is always challenging
of course Marissa and I when we took the
business over we both kind of sat down
and agreed that we'd speak from one
voice and so we of course have internal
discussions quite often and then how
that gets translated to the team is
spoken between both of us and and made
sure that it comes from comes from one
voice so I handle certain aspects of the
business and merca handles other aspects
of the business I think the number one
thing that drives a success for us is
mutual respect if you don't have that
and you don't respect what the other
person is saying and doing then you're
you're bound to fail and so it's really
important to both of us that we get back
to Common Ground and understand if we
don't agree on something which doesn't
happen very often that there's a common
ground of what direction is is best and
at the end of the day we're both looking
for the best interest of the business
and both looking for the best interest
of the overall
organization I think being married for
me and working together especially the
last 12 months I've realized the
importance of vulnerability and
communication and we've definitely
learned a lot about one another and
we've really built a stronger Foundation
than ever I am feeling really excited
about our future together and of course
with the business it's so funny I'm all
about just energy and understanding just
how the market feels and how like
conversations or situations feel and we
really try to read one another really
well especially working together and I
feel that we're more in sife than ever
especially with the stronger
communication that we've built yeah that
being said of course you know there's
challenges every day and we argue and we
get frustrated with each other and so
transitioning that from home vacation is
is very challenging we fight with that
every day and I think you know a lot of
people in our position probably have a s
similar issue and something that we work
on consistently but you know overall I
think in terms of what we have and what
we're doing we're very fortunate to be
able to work with each other the way we
do but you know there's always room for
[Music]
improvement currently lffa Bell is in
over 5,000 stores nationally looking at
all the new ads we just got with Food
Lion and and Target we just found out
today that we are going to start selling
in Target North Carolina so very excited
about that yes we have looked at
expanding outside of the US uh Puerto
Rico in particular for some data trends
that we've seen for some of our flavor
profiles and our products however right
now we have so much ground to cover
still domestically that it's a little
bit of a of a stretch for us right
now we are very excited to be sharing
our our new items in the next few months
we just launched our passion orange
Mimosa in our passion party punch which
will be in all Meyer stores in Ohio
starting in the fall and I'm sure we'll
have more locations as well but meer was
the first chain to see the opportunity
with those two new SKS going back to our
original premise with especially our
passion branding we really wanted to
create a wine that was approachable for
not only those who like wine or curious
about wine but are also enjoying rtds
and seltzers a brand and an item that is
approachable and not typically seen in
the wine department but is wine
based I really love seeing that she has
come this far I mean I remember several
years ago just talking about it her
telling me about this dream that she's
doing now and she's living it and you
know a lot of people they have these
dreams and they don't take off or it
takes forever but she just said you know
what I'm putting my foot in the door and
I'm getting in and she has whatever she
wants to put in here it's always a yes
because you know she comes in and she
promotes and we try to help promote her
as much so whatever path she wants to go
we will always support her 100% as I
believe we are the first stores that
have agreed to carry her when she first
started and we continue to carry her you
know because her product
works I think based upon what we've seen
since the Genesis of the relationship in
2016 and how it is exponentially grown I
I think that the sky is the limit so as
Luella continues to evolve we can be
part of their success
story we started out with just a handful
of stores and we now are up to 100
stores they have distribution in every
one of our stores so we're excited to
see the evolution of the brand Brands
and how the brands can continue to grow
so we think we're just at the beginning
we've doubled our business with them
over the past 3 or 4 years and and we
think we've just scratched the
surface I want my legacy to
be really based on the success of this
organization we've already grown from a
local Winery to Distributing our
products in in nine states but we have
so much more to grow and and so far to
continue to to go I would like my legacy
to be knowing that I've put my best foot
forward every day in this industry or in
my personal life to take time to help
people do the right thing and keep
building something special and I'm able
to do that through lumabella
[Music]
Winery